The Chinese Communist Party recently
proposed a constitutional amendment to
abolish term limits on the presidency.
This change would allow the current
president to remain in power after his
second term elapses in 2023. The bottom
line is that President Xi's extended
tenure will likely lead to more
repression at home and more
assertiveness abroad. Domestically, he's
rooted out his political enemies through
a broad sweeping anti-corruption
campaign. Moreover, the core of Xi Jinping thought,
now enshrined in the Chinese
Constitution, is that the party controls
everything. Xi is not a reformer. Freedom
of information and expression have
already been reduced under his rule, and
we can expect this to continue. While
greater repression won't be popular for
the Chinese people, greater international
assertiveness likely will be. Judging by
China's involvement in various economic
and military initiatives, Xi is
comfortable with pursuing power and
influence abroad. He's also initiated the
deepest military reforms in China's
history, and once those are complete,
China may move to blatant use of force
to achieve, in Xi's words, "the
rejuvenation of the Chinese nation".
What do you think the implications are of an indefinite ruler in China? Let us know in
your comments. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.